people of the internet retro records who
are here and guys it has finally
happened on thursday december 16 2021
the developers at avalanche spoke once
again about hogwarts legacy it lives you
guys it's actually happening we're
finally getting some news
but not
yet
what in the world am i talking about and
what does it all mean so if you guys
didn't see this yet let's be honest you
probably already have but if you didn't
at avalanche wb the official wb games
avalanche twitter page tweeted out the
following happy holidays from the
avalanche team we're excited to share
more news and updates on hogwarts legacy
next year now you guys know this is a
huge deal especially those of you who've
been following the channel for a while
if you're a newcomer you might be
thinking oh hey great they're talking
about this game again it's actually been
more than a year last september
september of 2020 is when we had that
first trailer the first official trailer
anyway at the ps5 showcase event but if
you're new here i also want you to know
this is the place for all the latest
hogwarts legacy news theories discussion
even old school harry potter let's plays
so if you enjoy the video today and you
want more make sure you hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss any
of our new videos unfortunately there's
some good news and some bad news here
alright i don't know about you guys if
you prefer the good news or the bad news
first but i'm one of those people who
always likes the bad first so let's go
ahead and get the bad out of the way and
the bad news is is that this is just an
incredibly brief update it's basically
an announcement of an announcement that
doesn't even have an exact date on the
announcement just next year now i don't
want to knock them too hard on this
because that's exactly what we've been
begging them for it's like just say
something please acknowledge that
progress is still being made that
something is on the way because since
the delay of the game all the way back
in january of 2021 we've gotten
virtually nothing at all so this to me
combined with the fact that we've got a
community manager now combined with the
fact that we got the announcement about
sumo digital red kite games working on
it little bits of trickling information
here and there starting to come out and
then finally we get the official word
directly from avalanche that yes more
news is coming and we're excited to
share it i knew there would eventually
be a huge marketing campaign behind this
and so i think this is certainly the
beginning of that so the good news i
think here is that next year is actually
very soon that could be incredibly soon
in fact it may even be as soon as
january 1st 2021 that is when wb is
having the back to hogwarts event it's
going to air on hbo max and this
essentially looks like it's going to be
a cast reunion of sorts from the
original movies now i do want to say
here and now i think this event is
strictly going to be focused on the
original movies getting all these casts
back together talking about some of
their favorite memories and really just
a tribute or a celebration of that
original series and how much it meant to
all of us but i certainly think there is
always a chance you know right
especially now with avalanche making
this announcement if not there then when
and that's of course when we get back to
the negative which is that it was
incredibly vague so next year i mean
that could be anytime next year however
we know that 2022 is set to be the
release date right so it's got to be
early 2022 when we start seeing more
right the game is still releasing in
2022 right look hopefully it is in the
early part of the year when we start
getting more info i tend to think it
will be in kind of that first three
month time range maybe right around when
fantastic beast is getting ready to
release i still think it's going to be a
holiday 2022 game but who knows maybe it
ends up being a summer game instead
we'll just have to see but i do think
this is an encouraging sign as i said
earlier when you take this into account
with all the other little things that
have been happening it's really starting
to add up and hopefully really starting
to build up to more information being
released about this game and then
hopefully the game actually being
released right because at the end of the
day that's what we all want to get our
hands on this game and to actually play
it if you haven't seen any of our old
school harry potter let's plays you can
check those out now on the right side of
your screen or if you want to catch up
on all the hogwarts legacy news then you
can hit the hogwarts legacy playlist on
the left side of your screen as always
thank you all so much for watching i
will talk to you again soon